thank you dolphins are renowned for
their intelligence so does that mean
that they have very intelligent sex
spoiler alert it sort of does but they
also have a dark side
oh God why didn't anyone give me any
warning
[Music]
why is that swimmer so close this is all
types of wrong
so yeah dolphin six
often males will actually form little
Cooperative groups in which they sort of
kidnap females until she becomes
receptive to their advances and they can
be quite forceful in that activity that
is a pretty amazing video because you
can see a dolphin penis
Dolphins don't have a breeding season
they breed basically all year and a
dolphin erection can happen basically
instantaneously because sex when it
happens for dolphins is very quick like
seconds long so he needs to be ready
when the opportunity arises do those
swimmers realize what their witnessing
oh it was so amazing we went out
snorkeling and the Dolphins were just
playing turned out they were
masturbating foreign
s are smart and will have sex for other
reasons apart from procreation and there
certainly seems to be some behaviors in
Dolphins around the world which indicate
that they
do things for pleasure and this could be
one of them it looks as if they're doing
a nice bit of a wriggle on something
that feels nice on their nether regions
down there
okay it appears to have a sea sponge
that it looks like it's carrying along
so I think what could be happening here
is gift giving the male has a sea sponge
now he's probably ripped that off the
ocean floor and you have to be big and
strong to do that sexy isn't it but also
when you show how big and strong you are
to someone that you're trying to mate
with it could also be an act of
aggression so he's saying I'm big and
strong so you better mate with me
oh wow so we've got some belly to belly
copulation going on how romantic they
getting their neighbors involved oh wow
oh God it's a swingers party each
species has their preferred positioning
these are spinner dolphins and their
preferred mating position is belly to
belly as they go along
oh I've never seen a video of this
before
[Music]
the baby just came up oh my god look how
vigorous it is
[Music]
dolphin females give birth in shallow
water where it's sort of nice and warm
and they'll often be accompanied by
other female dolphins who act as
midwives so if the mother exhausts
herself during the birthing process The
Midwives can actually scoop up the baby
and lift it to the surface so that it
can breathe there are humans in there
which indicates to me that this is
probably in an enclosure that they're
not wild dolphins keeping in mind that
putting a dolphin in a pen even if it is
on the ocean side is something like 200
000 times smaller than its range in the
wild and it's really bad for their
physical and mental health
yeah
yeah okay so the dolphin is harassing
human
this is the moment I was waiting for
dolphins are incredibly social creatures
and when they find themselves on the
outer edges of dolphin society that can
be for a number of reasons it may be
because they're not quite right to fit
in with Society it may be that they're
in a pen but it can lead to all sorts of
funny things like dolphins fixating on
humans as objects for sexual
gratification
this is actually a really dangerous
position for these humans to be in
sexual behavior is interlinked with
aggressive behavior in dolphins and I
actually spoke with a wildlife
photographer called Michael who had it
happen to him basically I spent a lot of
time on the Arctic in the water with
whale sharks Dolphins so I look around
and he was literally hanging
hanging next to me
less than an arms length with his eye
looking into my eye
but then he started literally charging
us
and I also felt one of my ankles was
being restrained which I just couldn't
figure out like what's happening
something is pulling my leg it was very
tight hard to get away from
it's only at home when I offloaded the
videos that I saw like oh yep that was
it
if he says no you can't descend it's
just a must on top of you and it's
blocking you
if you could go up a little bit it would
just pull you down again
near the end it was getting nasty the
problem here is not the dolphin because
that's just one of the
quadrillion whatever animals in the
ocean the problem is the interaction
with humans or humans interacting with
oh look how cute a dolphin that's the
issue we go into their environment it's
not the other way around it's not our
ocean it's their ocean
yet Michael's experience sounds
absolutely terrifying I mean being
pushed down in the water to the bottom
of the ocean is pretty much the stuff of
nightmares
it's hard to accept that Dolphins aren't
just cute and cuddly when it comes to
their sex life it really is an example
of how they're wild animals and they
really do benefit from being in the open
ocean being wild and free without human
interference and I have to say that this
is one case where I'll happily be in the
friend zone
foreign
facts then you should find my podcast
It's weekly and it's called what the
duck yes you can find it on the ABC
listen app and also anywhere that you
find your podcasts